you know like when feminists go like oh
and they had like their missiles these
dick shape things and blah blah blah and
I'm always thinking like well there is
physics and aerodynamics and all that
involved like if you have it's shaped
like a [ __ ] I don't think it's gonna
make it to another country let's you
frisbee it's gonna [ __ ] be a lot of
drag while people are talking about
eating fake [ __ ] that was Jesus
[ __ ] Christ
gee do you think I was like trashing the
president of something you guys are
really like : gage worse than that for
people everyone's got an iPhone you know
Hey look I can't say that I'll just say
he's gone they still came out with
another one right did you guys see the
picture of Donald watching his wife vote
a lot of trust in that relationship part
of me dies every time I go into a store
and I see something they go can we get a
phone number watching somebody give him
the phone number why would you do that
yeah I always give the same I - all area
codes they go what's your phone number
I'm like three two three eight one eight
two one two five it was really uh you
know you relate to adults differently
people that you knew forever
and I always hate it when somebody who
didn't have a kid goes you don't get it
man
you don't get it - you have when I was
like [ __ ] you I get it it's like a
rehabbing a dog but it's more intense I
was so upset that security like escorted
him out I wanted to talk like I started
my show blaming women for sexual
harassment that's how I started yes it
was a cert I wasn't being serious your
children
your Christian background is is part of
the the shower yes and I wanted to talk
to you about Jesus after well the other
thing why I bring it up some people
thought maybe you went a little too far
you know as far as what well they
thought that maybe you were being
disrespectful to the Christian religion
reason I'm telling you you need to go go
oh good lord
daddy just ignore him it's like three
days they flip out for three days they
try to bully you into an appeal and
ignore them when they're right in the
audience and you're playing to them I
tell them to shut the [ __ ] up in New
Hampshire Hilary's winning Virginia
really and there's a little kid here
somebody please take a photo of this
Last Supper first off thanks for calling
in a couple weeks back and so blessed to
have you sitting here in our 105 nine
studio yeah no problem I'm actually glad
I don't watch the news I had no idea the
economy was tanking so we came in yeah
that's great it's a Rolex
yes it is I finally bought one 25 years
in this business is it white gold or
stainless I don't know is it heavy
no then it's stainless thank you thank
you for taking my watch down a notch I
finally felt successful you wouldn't say
that if I had Brown a black girl I think
bankers should be forced to dress like
bankers back in the day with like the
top hat and the tuxedo so at least you
know what they look like so they can't
hide in public as they go to the mall
stress like the penguin on Batman
just waddle around please let me throw a
hot dog at you something you piece of
garbage you're not gonna go to jail
they're the worst
remember that we had this college kid
agent great guy but he used to book us
in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere you
know he's called me a Billy Scott bass
calling I have a gig for you in
Rhinelander Wisconsin now they don't
have a lot of money
but I can build around it it's at 12
noon in a hallway can you do it yeah
we've never taken a break in the middle
of a Gaston I know I had all this
momentum going I got to start all over
again
go ahead go to the card it comes the
second of the doubleheader
I love the racist white guy thing a
bunch of racist white guys they came out
of the forest
it's like where were all these racist
white guys the last two elections when
they could have voted against the black
guy they were fine I don't mind a black
guy but there's white lady you're
whatever in God neato you're an enigma
what because I'm a cap I know you know
it is you're not a good listener
maybe you know me for 10 years you have
no idea where I am it's all about comedy
with you and moving up the ladder this
is like that Hillary commercial they
have the little kids watching politics
[ __ ] little kids don't watch
politics there you go
so like two like this week what I want
to upload my podcast to Dropbox and it
wasn't working and if you want to see
something funny watch me flip out when
my kid is sleeping cuz I can't yell kit
and just listen to do it I quit early
grabbed my computer and I was just like
Mike my [ __ ] house this are you
getting out of an existing house enough
gone from a one-bedroom apartment and I
figured I'd finally go out and buy a
damn house and not have to deal with you
know some jerk living above me or below
me you know do my own little thing get
my little 12-gauge get a bunch of cans
of tuna get ready for the apocalypse
that's what I want to do you tell it the
way it is I love the pot I really don't
I don't read I go with my gut that's my
fancy way of saying I don't read I hang
out in bars I overhear stuff that
plumbers say then I repeat it on the
radio that's all I'm doing
I love the podcast I just realized I was
swinging my legs underneath this is your
buddy is videotaping do this telling
jokes dude if you took 90% of my text
mess
Edge's and phone messages and you put
him on the news you would run out of
podiums to put in the front of me me
into Rosa say to each other fatty so you
can't talk [ __ ] in the room with that
guy
yo one time this guy stepped me in the
bar dude [ __ ] you once I'm the president
who's giving me [ __ ] and I said oh yeah
I'll have you a [ __ ] job in two years